today's classic interview is sort of a
preview of a really good interview that
we're going to have for you next week a
couple years ago I interviewed Chris
Shelton who was a high-level
Scientologist and he held nothing back
he told all and the reason I'm going
back to this interview today is that
next week we will be doing a very
interesting interview with Ron Miscavige
and if the last name Miscavige rings a
bell it should because he is the father
of David Miscavige friend of Tom Cruise
and current leader of the Church of
Scientology his father Ron Miscavige
will join me next week for what I think
will be a tremendously interesting
interview and to get ready for that to
get in the mindset we're gonna go back
to my February of 2016 interview with
Chris Shelton I'm joined today by Chris
Shelton who's a former high-level
Scientologist he was a Scientologist for
27 years he's the author of the recent
book Scientology a - Xenu an insider's
guide to what scientology is really all
about love the title of the book so tell
me how did you get into Scientology I
mean was it was it through your parents
are you a second jet were you a second
generation Scientologist I was about
four years old and what was the earliest
memory or what what are your earliest
memories of Scientology my earliest
memories actually are hanging out at the
Pasadena organization back in the 70s
growing up and doing some classes doing
some some children's type classes
communication courses and things like
that it didn't make any sense to me it
was pretty confusing stuff so I was
gonna say what are what are children
taught like at what what types of things
are taught to kids who are saying in
Scientology well you're raised with the
lingo of course and some of the basic
concepts of it in terms of you know
you're a spirit and that sort of thing
but courses classes wise they have
children's communications course and
they have children's study courses and
things like that and when you well I
guess as it as it for people who aren't
all
he sort of initiated into this talk a
little bit about the levels of
Scientology and then talk to us a little
bit about what level you got to and sort
of what that means
sure Scientology promises a sort of
personal spiritual immortality and and
personal freedom is how they call it
right a sort of a godhood or you know
apotheosis sort of thing and they have
this divided into levels of services
that you do as you go as you climb this
bridge to total freedom they call it and
you know a sort of crossing from this
you know horrible existence on earth to
this wonderful spiritual immortality
sort of thing and along the way are all
these different levels through the
counselling they offer the first one the
first milestone being was called the
state of clear and this was something
described in Dianetics this is old back
to 1950 before you know predates
Scientology which is you know sort of a
full release from all psychoses and
neuroses and things in your mind that
are that are affecting you from past
traumatic experiences and whatnot and
you know and I have to just say upfront
it'd be wonderful if these things really
existed but they don't so you know but
this is this is how they described it so
first you have clear and then above that
are these higher levels of spiritual
awareness and ability which are called
operating thetan levels or OT levels
thetan being the Scientology word for a
spiritual being they don't call it a
soul or a spirit they call it a thing so
you have these levels that you go
through and that's where the Xenu story
for example comes in is it is at ot
level three and there are eight released
ot levels in Scientology and to what
level were you able to ascend I got to
the state of clear but like many many
many Scientologists that was achieved
and then taken away because there was
you know about three or four times now
they've done these reviews where they
they say Oh
yeah I know you you didn't really make
it and so now you're required to pay
more money because we you know didn't
actually get it done properly and you're
gonna pay to redo services you've
already done because we didn't you
didn't really achieve it but for me if
you can what is the cost average right
to get to the clear level what do people
more or less pay by the time they've
gotten to that point okay and that might
be over a period of how many years to go
but well at least a year I mean you know
at least that but generally speaking
people take years to get to the state of
clear because it costs a lot of money
and it takes a lot of time and they and
especially over the last 20 years or so
they've really been milking people so it
could be upwards of two hundred thousand
dollars and that's between you know
donations as well as the the counseling
you're paying for or they make you buy
Hubbard's lectures and listen to them
and his books and you have to read them
and there's there's a lot of costs
involved in Scientology that are sort of
hidden costs that you don't know about
until you become part of the system they
hit you up for money all the time in
your heart of hearts when you were
really in this right did you literally
believe all of the teachings of
Scientology I mean l ron Hubbard I've
read about him talking about his trips
to Venus and Mars I believe and you know
we thought we know about the the I
forget even the the age of the universe
under under the teachings of Scientology
but it's it's just an outrageous number
did you truly believe that or did you
always have some sort of doubts about
those stories no I I was for many years
it was very easy for me to be a science
denier because you believed l ron
Hubbard you believed what he says and he
you know castigate science and physics
and and I hate everything really that
disagrees with him and he claims to be
the only one who have discovered these
it's about life and you know you go okay
well there's a certain degree of
possibility that somebody can discover
something that nobody else knows and
then share his work so you go okay you
give a little bit then you give a little
bit and give a little bit and then
really what happens is before you really
have thought the whole thing through
after you know months and years of this
you're accepting things is true that are
absolutely ludicrous that on day one you
never would have accepted but as you've
progressed through this belief system
and accepted Hubbard's authority on
things you find yourself believing
things like you know the universe being
you know it's trillions and quadrillions
of years old and you know he could
travel spiritually to venus and mars and
things like that you know there are so
many allegations of assault and abuse
and violence in the Sea Org where where
you ultimately worked with in which you
worked ultimately were you ever arrested
yes I was personally it was one of his
juniors who did it
and there's a lot of physical abuse not
just physical assault like directly
somebody hitting you but there's you
know much much overworked sleep
deprivation the see organization is
Scientology's clergy it's the core group
of Scientology that are working 24/7 and
it's a paramilitary group so there's
ranks and ratings and people are saying
sir and saluting and all that and you I
mean there was a period of a week one
time where we were working on a
particular project where I I got about
three hours sleep over a five-day period
there's it's it's an intensely dedicated
group and they take it way too far in
how hard they're worked for the cause
and and there's a lot of burnout a lot
of people you know just crash and burn
and end up leaving and and the and at
one point I was in a high intensity
situation where somebody the senior
person to me got very very very
set with me over something I didn't even
do wrong that was what was really so
unjust about the whole thing and she
ended up you know beating me in front of
a roomful of people to make her point
that she was very upset with me she
struck me grabbed me and and beat me and
it sort of understood that you can't
retaliate in a situation like that
oh very much so it had I done anything
other than accept it I would have
instantly been sent to Scientology's
rehabilitation project force or the RPF
and ironically you know I ended up there
for anyway two years later but that's
that's that would definitely have been
the consequences of me retaliating or
speaking back or or even complaining
later to somebody else even after things
did chilled out if I had gone and said
this was wrong and shouldn't have
happened and all that she was in such a
position that it would have been
unquestionable it would be unthinkable
to have said anything against her you
recruited more than ten people the exact
number offhand I don't remember but I
think it was somewhere between 10 and 12
people to the Sea Org question was are
any of those people still part of the
Sea Org and to do you feel guilty for
having recruited those individuals yeah
I don't know for sure I know some of
them left before I did I don't know if
all of them are still in or not and
guilty yeah I guess I do
I am I certainly am NOT happy about it I
wish I you know I I of course at the
time was not doing it out of malice or
because I thought I was part of a con
job I honestly believe that what we were
doing was was truly making a difference
and was truly going to save the world
that those were the words I would have
used and in fact those are the words I
did use to recruit people so I was a
fervent believer at that point but then
looking back on it yeah I'm regretful
about it I wish I hadn't done that I'm
gonna remind everybody Kris Shelton's
book is Scientology A to Z new an
insider's guide to what science
is really all about let's take a break
on our TV and radio show we're gonna
continue a little bit longer with Chris
Shelton and talk about SP suppressive
persons the full interview will be on
our YouTube channel so Chris let's talk
a little bit about as I mentioned
suppressive persons you know my mom at
one point inadvertently hired a
scientologist handyman and I was sort of
left to monitor his work when she was on
vacation and he started talking to me
about Scientology and initially I
thought he was sort of bringing it up to
sort of make fun of it with me or poke
fun in some way and it became clear
immediately when I said oh yeah that's
the the religion based on that science
fiction guy's books right sort of
innocently he very quickly went and
talked to me about how no people who
believe that are suppressive and of
course I realize more than 10 years
later he was referring to suppressive
persons so explain to our audience sort
of what that status is and what that
means
yeah suppressive persons were originally
formulated by Hubbard in the in the 60s
as the antisocial personality and they
were presented as the kind of person or
the kind of personality that you would
read about in the sociopath next door
you know like that I got like a really
bad bad person a Christie or a Hitler or
a Napoleon as' or some of the examples
Hubbard gave and and of course those
people exist and they're it's very easy
to see in history and in the news that
such personalities exist however over
the company's few years what happened
was that label of calling somebody a
suppressive person started taking on
sort of internal political and and you
know control overtones where if somebody
started speaking out against Hubbard
they were automatically obviously
psychotic nuts because look at what
Hubbard was how great he was and so this
label of a suppressive person started
being used as the control mechanism
within the Church of Scientology and if
you were labeled a suppressive person
Scientologists assume you must have done
something to deserve it and because the
church of course
never do this to control people right
and so they just accept that if you were
declared or labeled this oppressive
person you have done bad things and they
don't even need to know all the
specifics of it
originally the it was written on a piece
of yellow or goldenrod paper your name
suppressive person declare and you know
her Shelton is - here my first Preston
because he did X X Y Z Y & Z Z and they
would post these up on noticeboards and
and everybody would know that they
needed to break contact with you forever
you were no longer you were persona non
grata and this includes family friends
business associates everybody sounds
like a you know in New York City and
parking garages around holiday time they
put up a board and they thanked people
who have tipped and so it's sort of like
a board of shame if your name's not on
the board you know people are I guess
supposed to think less of you this is
sort of the opposite they put up on the
board the names of the people that are
our suppressive what had you done to be
labeled as such I simply spoke my mind I
posted on the internet that I have
disagreements with Scientology I had had
a bad bad very long series of bad
experiences with Scientology because
they were persecuting me
and then they as a result of that they
declared me a suppressive person night
it was really simply exercising my First
Amendment rights you don't you don't
really have those rights in Scientology
they say you do but that you don't not
if you not if you direct that criticism
towards the church or its leaders and
and I you know whilst my fiancee I lost
friends I'd had for twenty years
overnight all gone and that was that was
quite devastating and that's that's a
it's a tool the the church wields to
control its members and keep them in
line
yeah we've spoken to Marty Rathbun
Claire Headley and Laurie Hudson and
they've all sort of told their story of
leaving and of separation and described
it similarly to how you're talking about
it
what were you able to leave in a simple
way or was it even difficult for you to
leave the Sea Org and Scientology it
took me nine months to what they call
route out or leave the sea organization
because I didn't want to work for them
anymore but I still wanted to be a
Scientologist at that point this was in
2012 I still I didn't I was kind of you
know okay I'm done working for this
group it's you know I'm not really
achieving my goals personally I'm not
happy
so after 17 years working for the Sea
Org I said okay and that's enough I want
to quit I went through the whole process
you have to do to do that and in
December 2012 I was no longer a sea org
member but I was still a Scientologist I
started being persecuted because at what
I didn't realize is that as an X sea org
member you're the lowest of above you
were treated as a third-class citizen
you are you know sort of like back to
the line we don't want you around that
sort of thing and yet I was trying to
make a go of it as a Scientologist as a
public Scientologist now I was kind of
pay for my services I wanted to you know
do take take part of all the goods that
I had been you know getting other people
to for all those years and then then
they weren't gonna have any part of that
and it got me looking more deeply into
what is this really all about that that
I'm being treated this way and that's
when I got on the internet and that's
when I went down the rabbit hole and
found out all about all the lies that
Hubbard and Scientology are actually all
about and it took me about three months
to get through a lot of that and really
delve in and and get the facts in the
matter and I was so upset I mean there
really aren't words to describe how
upset I was after spending 27 years of
my own life doing this and finding out
it was all you know so I started
speaking out and shortly thereafter I
lost all connection isn't I was declared
a suppressive person last thing I want
to touch on in the very limited time we
have left since the book came out
have there been repercussions threats
contact with Scientologists
I'm in direct communication sent my way
that indicated to me that they are
keeping an eye on me and you know I've I
have mixed feelings about it it's not
unexpected you know I've been a pretty
vocal advocate and critic and I intend
on continuing that you know the and that
and what that really tells me is the
force that my book is the truth and they
don't like it and that people should
read it well I mentioned once more the
book is Scientology a-to-z new an
insider's guide to what Scientology is
really all about we've been speaking
with the book's author Chris Shelton
Chris thanks so much for sharing your
story
absolutely thank you and they can find
the book on Amazon by the way